الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك سيليكون فاليؤكد ان
الودائع محميه وانه يدير الاعمال التجاريه
كالمعتاد
قاده امريكا وبريطانيا واستراليا يعلنون
خطه لتزويد كاميرا بغواصات تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه
عجل صالح ينتقد المبعوث الاممي ويدعو
لتشكيل حكومه محيده للاشراف على
الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه ويقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر قال
رئيس التنفيذي لبنك سيليكون فالي انه
بامكان المذيعين الوصول بحريه لاموالهم
وان الودائع محميه مؤكدا في الوقت ذاته ان
اداره البنك تسير الاعمال التجاريه
كالمعتاد داخل الولايات المتحده وتوقع
الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك سيليكون فالي
استئناف المعاملات عبر الحدود خلال الايام
المقبله
قبل ذلك اعلنا مجلس الاحتياط الفيدرالي
انه سيجري تقييما لاشرافه على بنك سيليكون
فالي بعد انهياره في ثاني اكبر فشل مصرفيا
في الولايات المتحده على الاطلاق وقال
مجلس الاحتياط الفيدرالي في بيان مقتضب ان
مايكل بار نائبه رئيس المجلس لشؤون
الاشراف سيقود هذه الجهود وسيجري مراجعه
دقيقه وشامله لكيفيه الاشراف على هذه
الشركه وتنظيمها
اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم ان الله
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع وضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خلال كلمته هو ان جميع اموال المودعين
ودافعي الضرائب في البنوك مؤمنه ويمكن
الحصول عليها من دون عائق وطلب من
الامريكيين الثقه في النظام المصرفي فقبل
هذه الازمه كانت الحكومه الفيدراليه تضمن
من خلال المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على
الودائع الودائع التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن
250 الف دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدو الماليه لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين لكن الوضع بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الذين يخاطرون بوداع
الامريكيين مختلف وفق بايدن لانهم لن
يحظوا باي حمايه فيما تعهد بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن ازمه البنوك معتبرا ان لا
احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
بيضا وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين
ولعدم تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان
تنتهي ازمه مصرفي سيليكون
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك حسين الطوط العربيه
واشنطن
بنك سيليكون فالي مجله نظام التامين
الفيدرالي يغطي ودائع تصل الى 250 الف
دولار ويحمي جميع الاموال النقديه لمعظم
الافراد في حساب المصرفي حجم المدخرات زاد
من 44 مليار دولار نهايه 2017 الى 189
مليار دولار في نهايه 2021
نمو القروض من 23 مليارا الى 66 مليار
دولار وجود ودائع اكبر بكثير من القروض
استثمار 128 مليار دولار نهايه 2021
معظمها في سندات الرهن العقاري وسندات
الخزانه الانهيار له تداعيات عالميه بينها
سوق العملات المشفره وتاثير سلبي على
الشركات التقنيه او الناشئه صحيفه
الجارديان العديد من الشركات والافراد قد
يخسرون اكثر من نصف ودائعهم
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لم
يفوت الفرصه لتوجيه سهامه الانتخابيه
للرئيس بايدن والقى بلومي على سياساته
الاقتصاديه مشيرا الى ان المزيد من
الكوارث الماليه تلوح في الافق مع ما يحدث
للاقتصاد الامريكي من ازمات والمقترحات
المقدمه حول زياده نسبه الضرائب في البلاد
اما مفوض الاقتصاد بالاتحاد الاوروبي فقال
ان انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي في الولايات
المتحده لا يشكل تهديدا خطيرا لاوروبا
وقال المفوض الاوروبي باولو
ان احتمال حدوث تاثير غير مباشر امر يجب
مراقبته لكن في الوقت الحالي ليس خطيرا
فقال ان تاثير انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
على الاسواق العالميه كان متوقعا لكنه
استبعد انتقال العدوى الى اوروبا
[موسيقى]
مسجد
وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي انطونيو
البانيزي شراء بلاده غواصات امريكيه تعمل
بالدفع النووي وانخراطها في مشروعا لبناء
جيل جديد من الغواصات بانه اكبر استثمار
عسكري في تاريخ استراليا
خمس غواصات امريكيه تعمل بالدفع النووي
كما ستتعاون في مرحله اللاحقه مع الولايات
المتحده والمملكه المتحده لبناء جيل جديد
من الغواصات لتعزيز الحضور العسكريه
الغربي في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ في
مواجهه صعود النفوذ الصيني رجاء الاتفاق
في اجتماع استضافه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن التقى خلاله رئيسي وزراء استراليا
وبريطانيا في قاعده سان دييغو البحريه
بولايه كاليفورنيا
اتخذنا خطوه كبيره لتعزيز اتفاقيه امريكا
وبريطانيا واستراليا اوكوس وسنضمن
لاستراليا بناء اسطول متطورا من الغواصات
النوويه وسنعمل على شراكات اخرى لتعزيز
اسطول استراليا الدفاعي ويجب الاشاره الى
ان تحالف اوكوس سيعزز التنسيق بشان
الغواصات النوويه مع بريطانيا واستراليا
الشراكه مع لندن وكامبيرا بهذا الشان
ستفتح وظائف كثيره ونؤكد على ان الغواصات
الاستراليه ستعمل بالطاقه النوويه ولا
تحمل اسلحه نوويه
قالت الحكومه البريطانيه ان مواجهه
التحديد الذي تشكله روسيا على الامن
الاوروبي سيبقى اولويه في سياساتها على
المدى القصير والمتوسط حيث اشاره الحكومه
البريطانيه في تقرير شامل حول الامن
والدفاعي وسياسه الخارجيه على ضروره
مواصله دعم اوكرانيا حتى تستعيد سيادتها
ومنع روسيا من اكتساب مزايا استراتيجيه من
الحرب واكدت ان احتواء روسيا والحد من
قدرتها ورغبتها في تقويد النظام الدولي
وامن بريطاني والمنطقه الاوروبيه الاطلسيه
سيكون هدف بريطانيا
علينا رئيس الاوكرانيس كان مستقبل
اوكرانيا يعتمد على نتائج المعارك في شرق
البلاد واضاف الرئيس الاوكراني ان الامور
صعبه جدا في الشرق الاوكراني ومؤلمه
للغايه مؤكدا على ضروره تدمير القوه
العسكريه الروسيه وافادت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه باستمرار المعارك في ضخمه
مشيره الى ان القوات الروسيه لا تتوقفوا
عن محاولات الاستيلاء على المدينه
الخلافات بين قوات فاجنر الروسيه وموسكو
تتفاقم معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكيه خلصت
الى انه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعطي
الاولويه حاليا للقضاء على قوات فيغنر
ثروه المعارك المحتدمه في ضخمه الاوكرانيه
خطر اساسي يهدد التقدم الروسي وهو خلافات
الصف الواحد بين مجموعه فاغنر التي تقاتل
في المدينه والكرملين
قد تكون فداء التالي لموسكو هذا ما ذهب
اليه معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي يرى
ان الدفاع الروسيه تعطي الاولويه حاليا
للقضاء على قوات فاجنر في ضخمه بعد الهجوم
الحاد من قبل بريكوجين على وزير الدفاع
سيرجي شويغو ورئيس الاركان العامه
هناك مواجهه مباشره لا تقل عن كونها
محاوله لتدمير فادنر وترقى الى خيانه
للوطن في حين تقاتل فاجنر من اجل باخموت
وتتكبد خسائر بشريه بالمئات كل يوم
[موسيقى]
الشقاق في البيت الواحد وصل لدرجه قطع
وزاره الدفاع الذخيره عن فاجنر بعد ان
استنفذت كامل ذخيرتها في المعارك وطلبت
موسكو بالامدادات الغريب ان الدفاع
الروسيه قطعت طرق التواصل مع فاجنر رغم ان
الاخيره تحققت تقدما لافتا شرقيه اوكرانيا
وضمينات لموسكو السيطره على المزيد من
الاراضي
بعض المحللين يرون ان موسكو تتارجح بين
رغبتين الاولى هي انتزاع بخموت كنصر
استراتيجي يمهد الطريق نحو غربي اوكرانيا
والثانيه هي التغلب على مخاوف بوتين من
طموحات بروجينات التوسعيه ومؤخرا كانت
تقارير غربيه تنبات بطموح بريكوجين لتحويل
فاغنر الى منظومه عسكريه موازيه
تحمل طابعا ايديولوجيا ويكون لها دورها
المنفصل عن الكرملين في اوكرانيا اذا عمر
العربيه
نشاتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
الشرطه الكنديه تعلن سقوط قتيلين وتسعى
جرحى دهسهم بشحنها في كبك
اهلا بكم من جديد دعا عقيله صالح رئيسه
مجلس النواب الليبيه اللي هي تشكيل حكومه
جديده وبمده محدده لتنفيذ القوانين
والاشراف على الانتخابات فقال صالح ان
الجانب التشريعي والقوانين التشريعيه
لانجاز الانتخابات ستكون جاهزه قبل يونيو
دعيا المفوضيه الى فتح سجل الناخبين من
جديد كما اكد صالح اصرار المجلس على اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها المحدد وان لا يتم
استبعاد احد من الترشح الا طبقا للقانون
واتهم رئيسه مجلس النواب رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد بيبه بالتسببي
في عرقله الانتخابات بسبب ترشحه للرئاسه
رغم تعهده سابقا بعدم الترشح كما وجه صالح
انتقاده للمبعوث الامامي عبد الله بتيري
الذي وصف مؤسسات ليبيه بانها منتهيه
الصلاحيه وقال لصالح النباتيري ليس حاكما
لليبيا ولا يجوز ان يحل محل اللي بي
نشد عشره من قيادات الاحزاب والكيانات في
السودان وفي مقدمتهم رئيس حزب الامه
القوميه المكلف فضل الله بورما ونائب رئيس
الحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الاصل جعفر
الصادق نشدوا القوات النظاميه التحلي بضبط
النفس وتفويت الفرصه على القوه التي
تستهدف وحده السودان وانه كما نشدت قيادات
الاحزاب القوى السياسيه والمدنيه التحلي
بروح المسؤوليه والقيام بواجباتها الوطنيه
والسمو على الخلافات وتقديم مصلحه الوطن
على المصالح الضيقه
في المغرب انتقد الديوان الملكي حزب
العداله والتنميه لتدخله في السياسات
الخارجيه ووصف الضياء الديوان بيانا صادرا
عن الحزب بشان العلاقات مع اسرائيل بانه
غير موضوعي وفيه مغالطاه كثيره
اعتبر الديوان الملكي في المغرب ان حزب
العداله والتنميه اصدر بيانا تضمن تجاوزات
غير مسؤوله ومغالطات خطيره عن علاقات
المغرب مع اسرائيل وربطها بالتطورات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله نعلم جميعا
وقع القضيه الفلسطينيه على وجدان المغاربه
وهي تاتي في نفس المرتبات قضيه الوحده
الترابيه وبالتالي فان قوه ديون سياسيه من
خلال عشر سنوات عجاف تحاول اللعب على
عواطف المغاربه من خلال مزايده بقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لا يمكن استغلال
التحولات الاقليميه للمشاهده بهدف عوده
انتخابيين او سياسويا الديوان الملكي في
المغرب اوضح ان القضيه الفلسطينيه من
اولويات السياسه الخارجيه للعاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس بالاخذ دول الملكي تجهز
العداله والتنميه حيال التطورات ديال
القضيه الفلسطينيه يعبر عن انزعاج واضح من
خلال البلاغ ولغته من المواقف التي يعبر
عليها حزب العداله والتنميه عشر سنوات من
التدبير في الحكومه للعداله والتنميه
ومشاركه اكثر من 14 وزير وكون رئيس حكومه
سابق سعد الدين العثماني وزير الخارجيه في
لحظه من اللحظات تقتضي ان يفهم ان المخطط
والذي يراس
للخارجيه هو ملك البلاد في رساله مباشره
الى اخوان المغرب اعتبر الديوان الملكي
المغربي ان مواقف الرباط لا تخدع
للمزايدات السياسيه او للحملات الانتخابيه
الضيقه فيما العداله والتنميه طالب قيادته
وقواعده بعدم التعليق باي شكل من الاشكال
تكراره هجوم حزب العداله والتنميه المعارض
على الدبلوماسيه المغربيه على خلفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه دفع بحسب مراقبين
السلطات المغربيه الى اصدار بيان شديد
الله جه يوضح مواقف الرباط من القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويوضح طبيعه استئناف العلاقات
المغربيه الاسرائيليه عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
بعد مرور سنه ونصف من حكمها في افغانستان
تواجه حركه انقسامات وخلافات واضحه بين
مسؤوليها تحديدا بين زعيم الحركه ووزير
الداخليه الذي بات يرفضه اي سلطه اضافيه
لقندهار
في افغانستان خلافات واضحه برزت في الاشهر
الاخيره داخل حركه طالبان لتنذر بانقسامات
بين قندهار وكابل بعد سنه ونصف فقط من
حكمها خلافات اساسها تقسيم المنصب بين
قاده قندهار اين يوجد زعيم الحركه ملاهبه
الله وكابول التي يتواجد بها الوزراء
والمسؤولون فازعموا طالبان اليوم لم تعد
لديه ثقه في المسؤولين في كابول الذين
طلبوا باصلاحات داخليه ينادي بها سراج
الدين حقاني الذي يريد تقليد صلاحياته من
ضمن الاصلاحات تشكيل مجلس شورى للحكم لكسر
سيطره الزعيم على القرارات والسماح
للفتيات بالتعليم والعمل والتفاهم مع
الغرب حول النقاط الخلافيه للاعتراف
بحكومه طالبان لكن زعيم طالبان يؤكد بانه
سيتخذ كل الخطوات التي من شانها عرقله
مسار تشكيل هذا المجلس ومن هذا يريد تقييد
السلطات كبار القاده في كابول الذين
يتخوفون من ان يقوم الزعيم بتعيين رئيس
وزراء اموال له والافضل بالنسبه له قاضي
القضاه الحالي عبد الحكيم حقاني حيث ذكرت
وسائل اعلام افغانيه بان وزير الماليه
هدايه الله بدري قدم استقالته بعد خلافات
مع زعيم الحركه على اثر ذلك ذكرت مصادر
العربيه بان زعيم طالبان يرغب باقاله رئيس
الاستخبارات عبد الحق وثيقه وتعيين احد
القندهاريين حتى يتمكن من الوصول الى كافه
ملفات الاستخبارات في الحكومه السابقه او
الحاليه الا ان جناح وزير الداخليه سراج
الدين حقاني يرفض ذلك ويتمسك ببقاء وثيق
في منصبه ويرفض اي سلطه اضافيه لقندهار
اعلنت هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه بي بي سي
اعاده واحد من اشهر مذيعيها واعلاهم
اجراد مهمه ما يضع حدا لخلاف حاد بين
المذيع والمحطه بعد انتقاده سياسه الحكومه
البريطانيه بشان الهجره
مصداقيه بي بي سي احدى اكثر المؤسسات
وثوقا في بريطانيا بعد ان وجدت نفسها وسط
سجال اعلامي اثارته تغريده لاشهر مذيعها
فبعد نهايه اسبوع حافله بانسحابات جماعيه
من صحفيين ومذيعين من برامج القناه اضطرت
بي بي سي لدعوه جاري الى العوده الى العمل
بعد تقديمها اعتذارا رسميا له
ن جانبه قبل الاعتذار ووافق على العوده
لكن تداعيات الجدل لم تنتهي بعد رغم
اعتذارها الا ان القناه تقول انه سيلتزم
بتعاليم القناه التحريريه ولكن ما هي هذه
التعاليم الحياه كما تقول القناه لكنها
ليست المره الاولى التي يعبر فيها صحفيون
في البي بي سي عن ارائهم السياسيه التي
يقولون انها ابسط حقوقهم المدنيه وعلى
راسها حريه التعبير المضمونه في بريطانيا
جدل بشان القواعد التي تريد بي بي سي
فرضها على موظفيها ومذيعيها فيما يخص
استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بما في
ذلك جاري الذي يربطه عقد خاص بالبي بي سي
من الان وحتى مراجعه التعاليم سيلتزم جاري
بالارشادات التحريريه كان من الصعب الوصول
الى التوازن لكن مطالبه
في تلك اللحظه
لحريه التعبير قيمه كبيره بالنسبه
للبريطانيين في البلاد ولكن من جهه اخرى
يرى المدافعون عن الحكومه ان تشبيه
ليونيكور سياسه بلاده بالنازيه امر حساس
ويتجاوز المقبول به في حريه التعبير وبين
هذا وذاك يضيع التركيز على مضمون القضيه
الاساسيه وهي قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه
والتي اصر لنكر على اعاده التذكير بها رغم
الجدل الواسع الذي اثرته تغريدته السابقه
من لندن ع روب عبد الحق العربيه
انتهى حفل اوسكار الخامس وتسعون على جمله
من المفاجات جعلت الاحتفالات تمتد حتى
الهند وماليزيا اللتين حققت جوائز نادره
في المسابقه الاهم في السينما العالميه
لكن المفاجاه الاكبر كانت في فيلم
الجوائز رغم انها نقادا شككوا اصلا في
امكانيه وصفه بالفيلم رغما عدم الاختلاف
على جودته
جوائز اوسكار لعام 2023
فيلم
الرابح الاكبر بسبع جوائز منها
وافضل اخراج لمخرجي الفيلم دانيال كوان
ودانييل
افضل ممثله ميشيليو
فاضل
لجميع الاولاد والبنات الصغار الذين
يشبهونني ويشاهدون الليله هذه مناره للامل
والامكانيات هذا دليل على ان الاحلام
تتحقق ذا جيمس
افضل ممثله في دور المساعد جيميلي كيرتس
تم ترشيح والدتي ووالدي لجوائز اوسكار في
فئات مختلفه سابقا والليله فزت اخيرا
[موسيقى]
افضل ممثل في دور ثانوي كي هوي كوان
امي تبلغ من العمر 84 عاما وهي في المنزل
تشاهد امي لقد فزت بوسكار
اما جائزه افضل ممثل فذهبت البريندن فريزر
عن فيلم
[تصفيق]
بدات في هذا العمل منذ 30 عاما ولم تكن
الامور سهله بالنسبه لي واريد فقط ان اقول
لكم شكرا على هذا التقدير
مهما ارتفعت الجدران على الحدود ستبقى
مسيرات المهاجرين على حالها
وفنزويليون وغيرهم يحملون ما خفا وزنه مع
اطفالهم سعين العبور الى ارض الاحلام
سلطات انفاذ القانون نجحت في التصدي لهذه
الموجه الجديده
في نهايه نشاهد التذكير بابرز عناوينها
رئيس التنفيذي لبنك سيليكون فاليؤكد ان
الودائع محميه وانه يدير الاعمال التجاريه
كالمعتاد
قضت امريكا وبريطانيا واستراليا ليعلنون
خطه لتزويد كامبرا بغواصات تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه
عجل صالح ينتقد المبعوث الامي ويدعو
لتشكيل حكومه محايده للاشراف على
الانتخابات
شكرا لكم على المتابعه والى اللقاء عند
المتصف
[موسيقى]